[MUSIC PLAYING]
MATTHEW SPALDING: Throughout
history, particular cities
have played a very
important role.
Athens, Jerusalem, Rome,
London, Philadelphia.
And you can kind of mark
the great stages of history
and the great developments of
human liberty by those places.
The American place
that was created
as a result of what happened in
Philadelphia is Washington, DC.
MOLLIE HEMINGWAY: Washington,
DC is where the action is.
If you want to affect
our federal government,
this is where you have to be.
And there's so many
opportunities to make a change.
PATRICK BRENNAN: I moved to
Washington to change things,
to improve and advance
American government.
JAMIE DANGERS: This is
where laws are made.
This is where policy happens.
MATTHEW SPALDING:
It's a place that
represents the idea of
America and a capital of one
of the greatest countries
in the world and in history.
And this is the place
to change the country.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Graduate programs in Washington,
DC are about a dime a dozen.
There are lots of them.
And most of them teach you
to accommodate yourself
to the status quo, how
Washington works today.
We want to do
something different.
We want to teach
you how to think
so you know those
first principles,
and you're able to
have good judgment,
and deliberate, and take action.
JAMIE DANGERS:
These days, culture
tells us to react, to respond.
And it's all based on
feeling, based on hype.
I want the change I am
part of to be substantive
and to be thoughtful, and
there has to be a grounding.
MATTHEW SPALDING: What's missing
in a lot of politics today
is we tend to have
one or the other.
We have a lot of
people that want
to talk about first principles.
And, of course, we have
a lot of people that
want to focus just on action.
It's connecting the two that's
the virtue of statesmanship.
TOM COTTON: Education
is about more than just
turning out good workers.
It should be about turning
out good citizens as well,
the next generation
of Americans who
understand the timeless
principles of our government.
And unfortunately, too
many schools and especially
universities not only
fail in that mission,
but they actively
repudiate that mission.
MOLLIE HEMINGWAY: Young
people who come to this town
don't have that
founding understanding
of how government should be
and how it will best operate.
JAMIE DANGERS: So I'm excited
about learning the larger
story, and how to incorporate
the wisdom of people
who came before us into a very
fraught culture right now.
LARRY ARNN: This
graduate school was
inspired by George
Washington to teach
these things, the large
things that a statesman would
need to know to govern
this country well.
MATTHEW SPALDING: We're going
to look at core documents,
original documents.
We're going to
study the writings
and thoughts of great
statesmen, great books.
LARRY ARNN: And
it will mostly be
taken by people who
work in the government,
and they will read old books.
They'll start with Plato
and Aristotle, Herodotus,
and Thucydides.
And they'll learn
what politics is,
and then they'll
learn what America is.
JAMIE DANGERS: I think
this program is unique
because it marries political
thought, and philosophy,
and wisdom from the
ancients with governance
and statesmanship
where we are now.
PATRICK BRENNAN:
There's a reason
why people study old texts.
They've proven their value,
but they're also rigorous.
And so you really
can't dumb them down.
MATTHEW SPALDING: We
want to study that now
not because it's the past.
We want to study it because
the past will help us now
to shape the future.
What the Van Andel Graduate
School of Government
wants to do is help
you see the North Star,
because if you
don't have that, why
are you involved in politics?
MATTHEW MEHAN: What excites
me most about teaching here I
think would have to be
the opportunity what
Socrates called protreptic,
the turning of souls.
I really think that this
school of government,
and this curriculum, and
these teachers, this place,
this town, you can
actually turn people
towards a life of deep
and prudent service
if you give them
the right principles
and you give them
the right tools.
MATTHEW SPALDING: We are in
many ways in a crisis today
about who should govern.
Are we still a
self-governing people?
The role of Congress versus the
president, the Supreme Court,
consent, these are
the core questions
that actually go back to
the very founding itself.
And as an extension of
our teaching mission,
it's only natural
that we are going
to teach those ideas which we've
taught from the very beginning
here in this city to all those
who wish to perpetuate liberty
in today's world.
LARRY ARNN: We want
to live freely.
That's not so easy
these days, right?
We do huge things.
We don't take any money
from the government.
Why?
Because we think it's
of eternal value,
and we think we
have a right to it,
and so we need a
freedom to let us do it.
MATTHEW SPALDING: There will
be many difficult and prudent
decisions required
to recover a stronger
sense of self-government,
a limited government,
a constitutional government.
It's going to take some time.
But we need to
prepare now to shape
those people who will do that.
It's not too late.
TOM COTTON: I want to
see the next generation
of American statesmen prepared
to face those challenges,
should they come.
And the lessons they
learn are being taken out
of the classroom at
Hillsdale and being
taken into the
halls of Congress,
and into the administration,
and into the courts.
MATTHEW SPALDING:
The greatest thing
that the Van Andel Graduate
School of Government
in Washington, DC
can accomplish is
to form a core of individuals
who have the knowledge,
and the determination, the
good sense, and the prudence,
of going out into the
world in order to turn it,
turn it back to its
principled course of the good
of preserving self-government.
Forming those kinds of
individuals, statesmen,
and being able to teach
them, and see them formed
would be the greatest
accomplishment,
and for the good of our country.